Yan
C
for
speee
spee
for
Fore fore
fore
foree
for
fore
foreign for
spee
okay
good
gotcha
I don't think it's
good
fore could cut
up
down
fore
speee
speeech
foreign
fore
speee
foree
spee
fore
for
drone strikes were increasing there were
suicide bombings in kalala and Mogadishu
and jok was on the ground snatching
bodies and flying them back to ships in
the Arabian Sea
almost as soon as I arrived I sensed
that things weren't going to go
well Mogadishu was seeing its worst
fighting in years and there were no
foreign journalists left in the
city my local contact Bashir Osman was
worried about my safety okay
okay it was a strange feeling traveling
with a dozen armed men in a decoy
car I still had my reporter's notebook
but what could I've learned in
conditions like
these before arriving in Somalia I'd
read reports that the US was Outsourcing
the kill list to local
Warlords among the most powerful in
Mogadishu was YF Muhammad CIA
known by everyone as IND ad white
eyes in an earlier life Inda ad had been
America's enemy offering protection to
people on the US kill list but the
warlord had since changed sides he was
now on the US payroll and assume the
title of General so he's saying that the
fiercest fighting that they're doing
right now is happening right here
the men fired across the rooftops but it
didn't make sense to me what we were
doing here or what the Americans were
doing here in Somalia arming this
warlord turned general for what seemed
like a senseless
War we got to move
so these were shabab Fighters you buried
here if you capture a foreigner alive
you execute them on the
battlefield
how did the Americans find men like Inda
ad and to what
end after a decade of covert War Somalia
was in Ruins half the country was ruled
by the local alqaeda affiliate the other
half by men like the general wandering
the streets with an endless kill list
and a band of
man every time we stopped people looked
at us nervously and I was told that my
very presence was endangering
them Basher would insist we leave
moments after we
arrived I wanted to see beneath the
surface of the war to understand what it
meant to ordinary Som
IES but I was passed from warlord to
warlord and soon realized the only
people I'd be able to meet were men with
guns you know when you are fighting with
enemy any option is
open no
mer for years Muhammad Kar was
Washington's man in
Mogadishu his methods were extreme but
Washington insisted kar's Services were
vital to their kill campaign who were
the people that the Americans wanted
your help tracking no I don't want to
talk you don't want to talk about that I
don't did they offer to fund any
operations yeah that one also no comment
you don't want to comment on that no
comment but you targeting people for the
Americans yes we arrest and interr and
release if they have not don't see
nothing that's our business and when
these American operations kill innocent
people what's the
impact America knows War they are War
Masters they know it's better than me so
when they funded award they know how to
fund it they don't need even to touch to
tell them they know very well they are
teachers great
teachers
foree how for
sh
for one go
in the miss
for
sh
and I
Ro
can't
for
I couldn't sleep I was getting in such a
depressed state I called my mother and
father asked them if they would take
care of my
kids and the most enjoyment I got back
in those days was singing in church
that's the only place that I was
actually singing during those those
times only thing I thought I could do
and make a little money to survive you
know I started cleaning
houses not the great darling love she's
not doing cleaning houses I said yes the
great darling love is she is cleaning
houses one particular Christmas I was
cleaning this lady's
bathroom and Christmas baby please come
home my Christmas record came on the
radio while I was cleaning this
bathroom and I just looked up and just
said okay all right darling this is not
where you're supposed to be you're
supposed to be singing there's a whole
world out there who wants to hear you
sing and then the move from California
to New York my career just took
off to have you here everything okay
with you everything is wonderful thanks
for being here come back and sing it
again next year of course I hope you
have a good holiday I have to plan what
I'm going to do I have to take little
jobs the bastard's got my daughters just
so you can keep your name out there but
if I didn't do those jobs then nobody
would really know who darling love
was as a young person I thought
everybody could sing when you start
getting older then you realize everyone
is not a singer and that these are gifts
and you have to share and go out into
the
world what a wonderful group what an
amazing
films
I mean each one of them for me was hit
so many different tender and horrific
places as I watch them and it makes me
even more curious to see who all of you
are and why you did these films so why
don't you start you two start introduce
yourself tell
me why you did a film within a film and
tell me the story of the film and also
how you two work
together I'm Joshua Oppenheimer I'm the
director of The Act of Killing
andanson I'm I'm the producer of the
active
K and thank you all for coming thank you
Barbara thank you to my fellow
filmmakers you're all so
wonderful um I began making this film
actually in collaboration with the
survivors of the
1965-66 genocide in 2003 we were trying
to make a film together about why they
are afraid about what it's like for them
to live with the perpetrators all around
them still in positions of power and
consequently what it's like for them to
live today with the fear that this could
happen to them again at any time when we
began that process the Army found out
what we were doing and told that
threaten the survivors that they mustn't
continue with the film the survivors
told me I was living with them they said
look before you quit before you give up
before you go home try to film The
perpetrators they may tell you how they
killed our relatives I didn't know if it
was safe to approach the perpetrators at
all but when I did I found to my horror
that all of them were open and
immediately boastfully recounting the
most awful details of the killings with
smiles on their faces in front of their
families and even their small
grandchildren
and I had this awful feeling that I'd
wandered into Germany 40 years after the
Holocaust only to find the Nazis still
in power and implicated because I knew
my own government had enthusiastically
supported the genocide when it had
happened and supported the regime that
was put into that that came to power
through it I showed this early material
with this with the perpetrators to those
survivors who wanted to see it and then
to the broader Indonesian human rights
community and everyone who saw it said
you're on to something so important keep
filming the perpetrators because anyone
who sees this anywhere in the world will
finally be forced to acknowledge the
rotten heart of this regime that The
Killers have built I then felt entrusted
by those survivors in the human rights
Community to do a work that clearly they
could not do themselves I spent safely
anyways I spent two years filming every
perpetrator I could find across North
Sumatra the main character who you saw
in the film anoir cono was the 41st
perpetrator i f filmed at the end of
that 2-year period and all of them were
boastful all of them were eager to show
me what they'd done eager to eager to
take me to the places where they killed
La they would launch into spontaneous
demonstrations of how they killed and to
understand really why how they want to
be seen how they see themselves I
started to propose to them very openly
look you've participated in one of the
biggest killings in human history I want
to know what it means to you and to your
Society you want to show me what you've
done so go ahead and show me what you've
done in whatever way you wish I will
help you film your reenactments but I
will also film you and your fellow death
squad veterans discussing what you want
to show and equally what you want to
leave out because that way we can show
what this means to you what this means
to your society and somehow uh how if we
can show I knew that if we could show
how they want to be seen how they see
themselves that the whole facade that
this was heroic would come crumbling
down but you also had really a strike of
luck because anoir really loved movies
and loved film and so maybe you could
talk about that because I think that was
a big segue for you to get accepted and
for him to understand what was happening
yeah when I was proposing this method I
mean in saying that I will help you red
dramatize what you've done in whatever
way you wish and I but I will also film
the process it is of course implied that
there is no film within the film film
there's no second film that they're
making that has any life they're only
making scenes for the Act of Killing and
also that the method was an a response
to their openness not a trick to get
them to open up but when I reach the
city of I work my way up the chain of
command from the countryside to the city
when I reached the city I found that the
Army recruited its killers from the
ranks of gangsters who hung out in movie
theaters and in fact called themselves
movie theater gangsters and they would
sell tickets on the black market and
then I gradually started to hear that
they would get get get methods of
killing from movies free man yeah and
they would call themselves free men
which was actually is in fact the the
word for gangster in Indonesian comes
from the word preman is preman which
comes from freemen but they somehow
identified this word free men with this
sort of ideal of Freedom that they'd
encountered in American movies and in
particular gangster movies and they
would talk about coming out of movies
what what most vividly an Elvis Presley
Musical on talks about dancing his way
across the street and killing happily so
movies and fantasy Were Somehow involved
with allowing him to do what he did
allowing him to distance himself from
the Act of Killing while he was killing
on the method I didn't expect that we
would come to these elaborate genre
inspired surreal
dramatizations that evolved organically
as anoir would watch the scenes we shot
and clearly disturbed by the content
would not dare to acknowledge really
what was bothering him he would never
dare to say this is awful because to say
that would be to do something he'd never
been forced to do which would be to
admit what he did was wrong and so
instead he would propose he would
present as an improvement he would lie
to himself and lie to me and say we can
if we can only fix the costumes or fix
the genre or fix the lighting or my hair
we improve our acting maybe we can we
can put this right and I think he was
trying in fact to to to to he was trying
somehow to to make it right for himself
by making it better in the movie and in
that sense what was fueling the journey
I think for him the whole time was
somehow his conscience and maybe it's
not so surprising in hindsight that the
fictional reenactments become this kind
of prism through which he finally
acknowledges the horror of of of what
he's done but also too wen't there some
lines in the film where um
Communists would come to him and say
thank you for taking my life and giving
him a medal and yeah actually we had we
had not we had wanted to show the scene
that came just before what you watched
but it was too long and it is anoir in
response to the growing sense of remorse
that he feels or or trauma that he
starts to feel propose stages his own
kind of bogus and dishonest redemption
in heaven in this grandio musical number
Born Free in a waterfall with dancing
girls and in the in heaven he's greeted
by his dead victims who thank him for
killing them and sending them to heaven
and he watches it it seems at first
delighted saying it's so powerful it's
so moving but in reality it offers him
no real Solace because it is a lie and
the very next line he says and where the
clip we we saw began he said the very
next line he says is okay yes but what
about the scene where I kill where I'm
strangled with wire because I think
somehow he was making this film to
somehow deal with and run away from that
that basic
horror would you like to add to this and
also your role in the film and what you
come away with it and I know that you
guys are doing another film together
which is the exact opposite yeah when
when I first met Jos I'm I'm based in
Denmark um and J was based in in London
um and I saw one of these very first
Clips with perpetrators we call it the
river walk walk where one was it was two
perpetrators and one was playing himself
as a perpetrator and the other one was
playing the victims and we dragging each
other down to the river and showing how
they killed and I thought this is so
incredibly important that this kind of
story must get a wider audience and and
that was my sort of first in in Walman I
I contacted Jos and we we started
talking and uh and we made it into this
International collaboration of course J
was already working with this huge group
of Indonesian filmmakers so they they
are the core of of that group and then
on top of that came uh filmmakers in
Denmark and filmmakers in Norway and
England as well so it's a collaborative
Affair oh seen as the most patient break
Brave wonderful producer on planet Earth
and that may in fact mean in the
universe for all we know so it was it
was more than just it yeah but we we um
we've worked together since 2007 and uh
we also now working on a second film
about the survivors and it's it's a in
in a way we see these two films as a
pair we've always wanted to do those
perspectives on this story and and we
hope to bring this other story out as
throughout sometime this year can you
talk a little bit more about doing this
film on the survivors and is this
difficult for you now that this film is
out and can you go back to Indonesia or
maybe you can't come out of Indonesia or
no we we we actually shot this second
film uh or the the last part of that
before we brought out the Act of Killing
because we knew knew that there was a
good chance that we probably couldn't go
back and then we have been editing in
between all this this work of bringing
the Act of Killing out and now we are we
are sort of making ready we want to go
and show it for the family who are the
main characters in this film and and
they need to see it all of them and and
we have to discuss it with them how to
bring it out and then we will do the
sound and the callor correction and all
that and and get it up it's a film about
a family of surv survivors with whom I
began this journey many a decade ago
more or less more than a decade they
find out who killed their son through
the first 40 perpetrators I filmed and
then decide that they are that they want
to break the silence that the family's
been sort of forced to live under and
confront all of the men involved with
killing their son it's unimaginable in
Indonesia for that to happen that's why
we have to handle the release very
carefully but it's turned into a kind of
poem about this silence born of Terror
and the necessity but also the trauma
that comes with breaking that
silence one of the most startling things
in your film is near the end when anoir
goes up to a spot where he has been
doing a lot of killing and maybe you
could explain what he was doing it's it
it just shook me yeah it actually is the
scene that follows this this clip we've
just seen so you've asked about the one
right before and the one right after
that must be good exactly at the end of
a 5year journey of filming we filmed I
filmed with anoir and his and the men
around him over for five years um 1,200
hours of material we filmed together but
the very next scene I filmed with anoir
after this scene was actually six months
later in time I went home and came back
and I had been I took him back up to the
rooftop where he where he took me the
first day I met him and where he showed
me how he killed and had and then danced
the Cha Cha Cha in the spot where he
killed people and he says and I take I
wanted to take him back because I'd
never been able to get back there and I
had heard all these awful stories the
first day I'd been there but we then
couldn't get access again to that space
I wanted to bring him back and have him
just say this happened here we did this
here we did this here because these were
stories we'd spent five years
dramatizing and dealing with we walk up
to the roof and anoir is trying to do
exactly what I've asked him to do and
suddenly he's sort of uh
attacked by this kind of racked by the
sort of bout of wretching this physical
re reaction to what happened what he's
what he's experienced there and then the
what what it's meant for him and it was
one of these awful awful moments where I
had this feeling that he's trying to
vomit up the ghosts that haunt him and I
wanted to put my my arm only that
nothing would come up because what
haunts him is somehow his past and we
are our pasts so what haunts him he is
the ghost that haunts him I wanted to do
this thing that we and our Americans do
in our Eternal delightful and ultimately
misguided optimism which is to put my
arm around him and say it's it's going
to be okay and in that moment of course
I knew this is not this is what it looks
like when it's really really really not
not not okay
yeah
before we go on did you two change in
any way from this
experience and also maybe talking about
the
anonymous people that helped you camera
people yeah the the film was made in
collaboration with a team of some 60
Anonymous 60 Indonesians these were
people who gave some of them eight years
of their lives to make this film some of
them changed their careers from being
University professors heads of human
rights
organizations um to make the film
because they felt it was that important
risking their safety knowing that until
there's real political change in
Indonesia they would not be able to take
credit for their work so really the film
ends in the credit scroll where the
screen fills with anonymous anonymous
anonymous anonymous one of them is my
was my second was my production manager
my assistant director my second camera
person but above all my main creative
sounding board on the shooting and that
dialogue I think is responsible for this
film having been embraced in Indonesia
as a work of Indonesian Cinema and it's
so important for the for the impact of
the film there and for its authenticity
that I've credited him as a co-director
the saddest part of releasing the film
is that he can't be with us tonight
because it would be dangerous for him um
even though the film is helping to
catalyze a transformation in how
Indonesia is now talking about its past
just the question about how we've
changed I kind of am tempted to ask Cena
how I've changed and vice versa but I'll
Hazard a guess about myself and let Cena
do the same about herself I guess I've
um I've probably become more
accepting less willing to condemn or
judge another human being as a whole
while utterly intolerant of any
justification for harming others or for
the ways in which we are all dependent
on the suffering of others for our
survival and our
living I think I mean I've learned an
awful lot from working with Josh and
from meeting these people and it's also
working with all our Indonesian uh crew
members um
and I think the most important thing for
me in terms of of U the way we do our
film making is that that uh doing this
project pro has been an enormous
struggle and the fact that we just
continued and continued and continued
and that it actually worked it given a
little bit more confidence that it is
actually possible to bring a film like
this out yeah thank you
thanks Zach Zach and Lydia can you tell
who you are and really talk about the
film cutie in the Box sir and the themes
of it and how you came to it and the
relationship between the two artists
because we really saw in the clips
really the relationship of one
artist and it's so much richer and it
really speaks about marriage and
competition and helping each
other sure I'm Zachary hining uh
director of cuti and the
boxer I'm Lydia Pilcher
producer thanks so much for having us
here it's been a real pleasure um so I
was introduced to the shinoharas in 2008
uh by a good friend of mine who's a
photographer at the time um so I'd only
seen pictures and really knew nothing of
of their art um or their history um and
I showed up at their Loft when afternoon
um with a
camera and usio was performing one of
his boxing paintings um and so here was
this half- naked 80-year-old man hurling
himself at a canvas uh with paint
splashing everywhere and it was kind of
pure spectacle um and noro uh his wife
was sort of off in the wings and and um
making sort of sly comments along the
way and and saying things like well you
know I'm the one that chose the colors
for this painting or um you know I'm the
one that that had the idea uh for this
painting and there was this immediate
tension and this immediate contrast and
and at first I thought well what a you
know beautiful sort of study in contrast
you had this sort of archetypal male
character um you know who she is termed
bully um who is and and is boxing and is
making sculptures of motor M Cycles um
but happens to be quite short and and
and slight um and you know everything is
about being Brash and bold and his act
and his performance is his art he he
sort of coined this term action is Art
and um and then his wife uh you know
sort of in some ways opposite you know
very self-reflective her art is all
about her past iio has never never
thinks about the past and noro sort of
lives in it and um her art very precious
and careful and and beautiful and and
you know 60 years old and and has
pigtails and this sort of platinum white
hair and there was so much just sort of
on the surface to look at um and there
was so much sort of inherent Beauty and
and the kind of caricatures that that
they played um that visually I thought
you know it would be really interesting
and I wouldn't have to explain much I
could kind of watch and sort of show um
you know how unique and impressive uh
they were um but then it also was clear
that these sort of archetypes that they
played you know were much more
complicated and and that I could sort of
chip away at them and sort of see how
you know the two of them could kind of
flip-flop and and cutie and Bully wasn't
as you know simple as that um and that
was also that was also clear there was
this clear uh resentment that that uh
noro would sort of you know it would
sort of seee in all of their
conversations um and I I was wondering
kind of where that resentment came from
and the answer and really the reason for
making the film came in noro's artwork
um this series of comics called cutie
and Bully um in which he has created
this Alter Ego of herself named cutie um
and it really kind of Chronicles uh a
few years early in their marriage um
where you see the pain and and struggle
it was for a woman a 19 years old who
married um usio who's 21 years older
than him and and became basically his
assistant manager translator cook and
everything else um and kind of gave up
her aspirations to be an artist um you
know to service him and um and there
was there was so much depth obviously to
to the history of the relationship but
also what was interesting was the kind
of um the way she had reconstructed the
past in a kind of almost humorous way
and it became interesting to see where
the line between her exaggeration of the
past and where the truth actually was
and where the truth was was in this sort
of contemporary story where I was
following them um in in their daily life
and and trying to figure out this kind
of fundamental question of why these two
people that seem to be arguing all of
the time are still together after 40
years um and what you what it means to
be in a in a relationship like this and
and you know uh themes of enduring love
and creative sacrifice and and um how do
we kind of figure out uh you know what
what keeps two people together and and
how complicated that could be so um
those were all the kind of questions
that came up as as I kind of went on
this what ended up being a 5-year
journey of of you know filming them and
documenting this unconventional life ah
but there was also so much more there
was drinking there was their son and
that whole relationship maybe you could
talk about that and he's also an
artist yes um so usio really was more
famous for his parties than his artwork
really uh he was sort of this on font t
of the of the 70s Soho art scene in New
York um friends with Warhol Rosen Quest
and and renberg and and uh you know it
had this Loft on on Broadway where
dancers and Painters and photographers
would come and um you know he would
throw these parties and he and he was a
heavy drinker and um uh would entertain
um and alcohol I think became a crutch I
mean he never was a successful
financially successful artist um
you know but was sort of known for for
his personality more than an art more
than his art um and um and he never
really sold anything right right I mean
he's famous for sort of what he did in
Japan before he moved to New York and
that work unfortunately isn't around
because he left it on the street and it
was never sort of preserved um so there
are a few pieces that are in museums and
in Europe and all over Japan that and
he's you know written in the history
books but his work that he did in the
New York uh it never sold for various
reasons um but actually in the film you
discover that um about 10 years before I
met them he he stopped drinking um and
their
relationship shifted and softened as a
result um but where the the Sun comes in
is Alex Shahara is a brilliant artist
and um you know was raised in this
environment that I Des described I mean
I you know we I shot a lot with Alex
though he plays a relatively small role
in the film but um you know he would
tell me things
like um my parents would would go out at
night and I would stand at the top of
the staircase in this giant scary Loft
with a wooden kindo sword um to protect
myself um and you can just you look in
his eyes and you see um you know the
sort of absence of of you know his his
parents and his Youth and and what
that's done and um and how it's affected
him as a person how it's affected his
artwork how it's affected his
relationship with his parents um which
is you know obviously strained and and
the real role I think
um is to really you know show the this
the unfortunate sacrifice really that
they chose to make in the pursuit of of
Art and to really question whether that
was worth it or not and to see the other
side of the kind of the romance of you
know when you think of 60s and70s
downtown art you think of what's created
the the greatest works that live in in
the Museum of Modern Art in New York but
do you see what the toll was on their
families do you see um you know what
what they had to do to sort of um you
know to to make what what they wanted
and and so you see both sides I think in
in noro you see noro's um implicit also
in in this this sort of problematic up
bringing of her child so uh you know
cutie and Bully again it's it's just
chipping away at what we kind of Define
as the the villain and and the victim
also her art is pretty
provocative can you speak to that a
little
bit yes I mean she and also too when you
showed him the film he made some
comments um about the second half which
is showed all of her art in it that that
could have been
cut yes this it's a great story when I
first showed them the film after them
not seeing anything for five years and
and in this film I mean it's you know
the
the my goal was really to make the most
intimate and personal uh film I could
and so that's why it took so long but
you know there's a scene in which I
follow iio into the shower and he gets
completely naked and walks and and he
you know it was a point where he didn't
think twice about the fact that there
was a a tall white guy with a camera
right next to him as he was showering I
mean you know it was that level of of
you know of uh Comfort um so I showed
them the film and and uh turned the TV
off and usio was the first to stand up
and ask so this is a love story um and I
sort of said well well in some way ways
yes and and he grunted and looked kind
of disgusted and um you know usio is a
egomaniacal artist and he feels like he
that this film was supposed to be about
him and this film was supposed to be
about art um and his art um and so he
decided that it was boring and that I
should cut the last 30 minutes which is
essentially the point in the film where
noro kind of gains her due and um and
the roll reversal kind of is completed
um and noro though on my behalf argued
you know uh that everything that he said
was completely wrong um and the movie
was playing out in front of us um so you
know she's really taken ownership of the
film and and uh in a way that we had all
hoped for is sort of using it as as fod
or another weapon in this eternal battle
that they have uh with one another and
and um you know it's really her story in
a way way and I think um usio has
embraced that as as he's seen the film
um countless times and and in a way the
kind of shift that was occurring is it
was just only galvanized as a result of
of the film and reaching an audience
that that usio has commented on is is
not an art audience it's an audience
that responds to emotion it's an
audience that will get up and clap or
cry and that never happens in an art
gallery and so I think uh you know he's
he now says that he wants to make art um
you know that will be more cinematic or
to give that you know impression to
someone um you know so it's it's really
been interesting sort of
following um how their lives have
changed as a result uh of the
movie so
Lydia can you talk a lot about your role
and what Drew you to this work and to
Zach sure
um I um I mostly produce um in a
documentary crowd I'll say scripted
fiction
films um because docs are dramatic and
narrative and so um but um I had I had
just finished um producing a film with
wet Anderson Dar young limited and I
came back to New York and a mutual
friend introduced Zach and I and um Zach
have been filming for about a year
weren't you working together on the same
floor something well after we met and
after we decided to work together Zach
moved into my office so then we were on
the floor for together yes he hasn't
left um but but I you know he sent me
some footage I I looked at it um I was
you know it was all in Japanese none of
it was translated Jack Zach had been
filming for a year often not
understanding what they were saying but
just relating to the characters
emotionally I think um but I thought the
cinematography was Exquisite it was just
it just you know was just shot so
beautifully and the artists were so
charismatic and they were just you know
they they had that screen presence and
there was an authenticity to their world
and their life they lived in the moment
you could see that there was something
very aspirational about whatever was
going on and we weren't really clear
what was going on I think and that was
part of what Zach was looking for some
um sanity Point well I think like wanted
you know a partner that could help
figure out the structure for the film
because at that point I think there was
about 300 hours so we um we found two
editors um who who were a couple one
spoke Japanese and one was American and
um we began a process of sort of
bringing that footage down to about 10
hours and having some of it translated
subtitled and really looking for the
story because Zack had started thinking
maybe it was going to be a short film
about usio you know in his action boxing
painting and I think I think that um the
process of making the film you know in
was a series of Revelations and I think
one of the you know one of the first
Revelations was the discovery that that
noro was doing this comic book series
and it it it was something that didn't
reveal itself for a long time and then
and Zach came into my office one day and
said you know she's drawing these Comics
that's about them and well I said and we
looked at a couple and then we said well
let's see more and I think that this
fueled noro as well because she began to
you know she began to exude more
confidence in her role in the situation
and she began to put herself out a
little bit more so that when you get to
the point where the G Gallery owner is
coming to look at ushio's work she says
I'd like you to look at my work too and
this is something that you know I I feel
like in retrospect looking back that the
film was sort of inspiring her to step
up and you see her voice emerging as
part of something that's really
happening um but I think also the one of
the beautiful things for me in terms of
being involved in the film really was um
the way um you know Zach approached the
craft and you saw it in so many
different ways all the time um you know
he made the Bold choice to animate some
of her comics which I thought you know
wow for documentary is this is you know
bold and it's it's um different and and
yet at the same time it was always there
was an Essence that was always there and
how could the craft of film making be
used to bring that Essence forward in a
way that that um ultimately I think
penetrates in a very deep emotional way
and um so it was very interesting to you
know to be able to support this process
with Zach and I think the other part of
it that I personally really loved and
really loved the process of was the
music which I think you should say
something about the music because I love
the way you talk about it definitely uh
the composer is yasuaki Shimizu um I was
originally looking for a new york-based
based in we're based in New York um
composer um and for what for whatever
reason my sensibility in music has
always been more minimalist and and kind
of sparse and and a bit sadder in tone
to be honest um and I heard a friend of
mine had sent me this CD called
pentatonica from Shimizu and Shimizu uh
lives in Tokyo um is in his 60s was a
member of ymo and the orb which were
these kind of experimental electronic
groups out of London in the 70s and um
you know had really never done scores uh
was you know had has has probably
recorded over 20 albums and is certainly
a champion in um Japan and came became
famous um internationally for kind of
reimagining the the uh Bach Cello suites
with saxophones um which seems odd um
but there's a quality to his music
that's kind of both um very rhythmically
challenging but also Whimsical and
playful at the same time so I put the
music with some of these scenes um that
at first kind of seemed a bit morose in
tone and and all of a sudden this sort
of the the humor and and kind of
playfulness um you know kind of was was
coming out of these scenes in a way that
I hadn't seen but also maintain this
kind of severity and and the drama and
uh you know complicated nature of the
relationship at the same time so it was
one of these things where you know you
could never have kind of imagined what a
very very specific and bold um you know
and very unique Music Choice combined
with with something that had already
kind of established its own tone would
create something you know new as a
result instead of really kind of trying
to uh do that process myself and and
really you know it it turned into
something that I hadn't expected but um
I got the the opportunity to go over to
Japan and work with Shimizu for two
weeks after about six months of working
over Skype um and his wife is this
Italian woman who acted as translator
and um on these Skype calls the two of
them would would bicker and kind of
argue over how to translate um what we
were talking about much like the
subjects of the film um so it became
this meta meta documentary but uh so
Sunday night both of these artists are
coming is there
anything unusual about what they might
wear or
yes well they are kind of fundamentally
unusual so everything that they do I
think um has a certain charm but iio
actually the story between ushio's
outfit is that uh he came from a very
poor modest um background in in Tokyo
and he sold his first painting um in I
think 1960 or 61 or his first big
painting and he went out and bought a
tuxedo uh for the opening um because he
thought he needed one and and that same
tuxedo still fits him uh 50 years later
so that's what he's wearing um and uh
noro picked out a very kind of funky
dress multicolored um and and she'll be
sporting her pigtails uh so I think
they're going to you know they'll be
quite the the sort of um interesting uh
thing to to witness on on the red carpet
with all the other uh you know
celebrities and
yeah okay
great okay Richard and Jeremy can you
introduce yourselves and introduce the
film um I'm Richie Ry director of Dirty
Wars I'm
uh I'm uh I'm Jeremy skill I'm a
journalist and uh I guess my title is
I'm producer of Dirty
Wars so
um I guess the introduction is uh to the
film is you know I became a war reporter
um when the Iraq War Began because I
thought it was the most shameful moment
in American journalism my lifetime um
not just the echo chamber that led to
that war but the way the embedded
coverage that uh that characterized it I
mean we saw that war um we saw it filmed
from the noses of bombs and we heard it
narrated To Us by by former generals on
cable news and the cameras were never
allowed to go to the other side of that
whole media and mil milary apparatus and
show us how people live the war on the
ground every day the Iraqi civilians uh
who who experienced it and so I became a
war reporter and went over there and
tried to do the only thing I knew how to
do which was go and tell the stories of
the civilians who were living the War uh
and I met Jeremy through this process
and we became quite close because we
were both covering that war and like
everyone I know who tried to do that uh
it was an incredibly traumatic
experience and we sort of made it
through because we had each other to
support each other through it
um so we had been tracking over the last
few years a process um you know in Iraq
and Afghanistan where a covert war was
eclipsing a conventional War um I'd be
embedded uh in with Marines and marger
wherever uh and you'd see you know you
go on meaningless presence patrols
during the day where your only purpose
was to try to get shot at so you could
return fire or find you know Target
locations for later uh working on
development projects that were all a
waste of time that all collapsed uh and
then at night hearing about hearing
about these night raids uh where uh
these daring raids where Taliban were
being killed and captured but by units
that we had no access to uh we couldn't
interview their commanders uh we
couldn't embed with them uh we couldn't
get anything more than a few lines and a
press release about what was happening
so when we began this story uh Jeremy
and I thought this would just be you
know uh I mean maybe a print article for
a magazine maybe a short film for
television about in Afghanistan how this
covert war was eclipsing a conventional
War and what that met the implications
of that um but what we found was uh I
mean the story of this family in gardez
in a night raid that went particularly
wrong uh where uh two pregnant women
were killed uh along with a an Afghan
police officer um and and another two
other people um and there was a cover up
where the bullets were dug out of the
bodies of the women and the family were
blamed for murdering their own daughters
um H and at the end of this
investigation we discovered that the
units responsible for this were not part
of the NATO command in Afghanistan uh
they were part of the of J The Joint
Special Operations Command this Elite uh
covert force that is uh responsible
directly to the executive wing and that
operates globally uh is supposed to go
after the you know most highlevel
strategic Targets in the world they're
supposed to do hostage rescue missions
or if a nuclear weapon is stolen from
the Ukraine they go and they track it
down um and yet they were kicking in the
doors on Farmers uh in Afghanistan and
so we um uh we began to look into what
they were doing in the rest of the world
and so when we started three years ago
when we knocked on the door of a house
in rural Afghanistan and started to talk
to this family we had no idea that the
story of this family would end up taking
us to Yemen and to Somalia and Beyond
and we certainly never imagined that we
would start the film talking to Afghan
victims of yeah US Special Operations
forces and we would end the film talking
to American citizens whose own family
members had been killed by the very same
units and also too didn't you get very
emotionally involved with many of the
people when you would go and you would
discover the deaths of many of these
people and the kind of trust and the
openness that brought you in yeah yeah I
um uh first of all I want to just say
that it's an incredible honor to be um
among such incredible people uh in this
room tonight and um I have great
admiration for all of the folks who uh
made the short documentary films and we
got to meet them last night and it was
really uh it's it's it's a stunningly
amazing um group of people and I'm just
I think we're all honored to be with
each other but I also want to bring um
other people into this room you know
filmmakers and and journalists uh can be
Thieves by Nature you know you steal
people stories and often times you don't
look back or or go back to share with
them uh what you actually did um with
all that time that you took from them
and you know forcing them in the case of
our film or asking them to share the
most horrifying painful episodes in
their lives uh and I think a lot of
people in Conflict zones and War zones
have just gotten used to the thievery
that is international journalism and uh
our credit role in our film is
obnoxiously long um but it's long
because so many people um gave up
something to make the film and uh you
know I'm so proud that Sarah isach is
nominated for a documentary short uh an
incredible group of very very brave
yemeni media activists um made that film
possible and it's the first time Yemen
has had a presence here at the uh at the
Academy Awards and we have two Arab
women filmmakers that have been
nominated one of whom is sitting next to
me you know we're living in a moment
where we have a Democratic president who
won the Nobel Peace Prize who is a
constitutional lawyer by training and
who is presiding over a global
assassination program and is not only
asserting that the US has the right to
conduct drone strikes in whatever
country it pleases or perceives a threat
to its own interests um but that the US
is right to do it and and what we tried
to do in our film and it was made
possible because of Brave Somali and
Afghans and yemenis who who won't be
interviewed on TV stations whose names
don't go down in the history books but
they made this film possible what we
tried to do was to tell a story uh that
we don't often have to confront in our
society
you know when the school shootings
happen in in New Town uh or Virginia
Tech the media coverage of those
episodes is incredibly powerful why uh
because they're telling us the stories
of the children that are killed or the
teachers that threw themselves in front
of a door I'm sure all of us remember
after New Town seeing the front page of
the New York Times with the
listing of all of the children who were
killed and their ages and it it'd be a
name and then six a name and then seven
a name and then six and and and when the
Boston Marathon bombing happened we all
heard about the 8-year-old boy who had
drawn that beautiful piece poster and it
went viral around the internet before he
was so savagely blown up and and and and
the reason I bring up the media coverage
of it is because they're they're they're
doing what journalists should do they
are forcing us to
empathize uh with the people who we lost
and to imagine the future that the
children who Drew those pictures would
have had um or the lives that they would
have led um and their deaths are
meaningful and they teach us something
about our society we almost never do
that with people who live on the other
side of the barrel of the gun of our
foreign
policy but you did that in your film I
don't you know we we we tried I think
you know the the great you know anti-war
activist priest Philip bar who I had the
honor to know he was one of the
kensville n and sort of this epic uh
defro priest who married a nun and
burned draft files during the war in
Vietnam um when he was dying of cancer
at the end of his life I I remember
talking to him and he said um uh you
know what I want on my on my Tombstone I
just wanted to say he
tried and I think that's that's that's
what documentary filmmakers I don't
think any of us believe that our one
film is going to change the world but
we'll be damned if we don't try to
change hearts and
minds but I think also what you did your
film did was really bring us into the
lives into the pain of the people that
you filmed and it was almost like a
promise to them that we're going to find
out what happened and we're not going to
leave you and we're going to come back
to you and that was very power powerful
Rick and I would travel when we were
traveling around the world together we
we would uh even when we had raised a
bit of money to make the film I mean we
maxed credit cards out I kind of took a
grant that was supposed to be for one
thing didn't tell the funer and kind of
put it toward the film we would always
stay in the same hotel room I mean we
really we had been friends for a long
time but we really became like family
and we would talk we would stay up on
nights when we were supposed to get up
early to do a shoot just talking about
um the responsibility that you have as
someone who has entered these people's
lives to do to to try to bring some
justice for them it's not that you just
want to make put a film out in the into
the world like you're writing a novel
you want Justice at the end of the day
for the people that you you worked with
and I I would I would be remiss if I I
didn't say that um uh our co-writer my
co-writer and the co-editor of the film
who is so much more than all of that he
was really the person who helped us find
a story that we had lost sight of in our
own shooting is is here tonight and he
really should be on the stage with us
his name is David rker and he's there
tonight and
anyway
so is he coming up I just I'm just
saying in a just world he would be you
know let's make it just I think it's I
think it's okay he he wed he's he's a
shy man no well but can we just see him
can he come
up fine all right just say just wave
David there you go okay well I mean one
thing I mean just before we we we pass
the
is um it it was really easy over the
course of making this film to get really
depressed and feel like it was worthless
and why the hell were we risking our
lives in a in countries that no one
cared about doing a covering a story
that no one was debating uh for a film
that you know no one might see in the
end um and the thing that uh kept us
optimistic and kept us going was to
think about all the people around the
world who risk their lives to help us
bring these stories here here um not
just about their sacrifice but about the
Deep faith that that represented in the
American people um they believed that if
American audiences knew what was being
done in their name but without their
consent or their knowledge around the
world that it would somehow change
things that it would fundamentally
matter to them um and so in those dark
moments in Mogadishu um we decided that
we would refuse to be more cynical about
our own country than the the our
country's victims uh who risk their
lives to have these stories be told so
um uh we just you know want to thank you
all again for for for allowing us to
keep our promises to everyone who worked
on this film uh who who that we would do
everything we could to bring their
stories and share them with American
audiences and to hold on to the hope
that uh that people around the world
have for us that we can you know begin
to have the national conversation we
should have had a decade ago uh but we
can turn things around
and and I think that you did that so
clearly because as a viewing audience we
really felt the pain of those people we
felt it seeing the dead bodies and then
we felt your Vigilant struggle to try to
figure out what happened and to come
back to them and let them know what you
had learned even if it risks so much for
both of you so thank you very
much okay the square do you want to
introduce yourselves and talk a little
bit about it um Jan N Jam and I'm the
director of the
square I'm H Karim Ahmed and I'm the
producer of the squ
and I guess I mean well I'm I met you 15
years ago right when I made a film
called startup.com and I have to say you
know um I made my first film with Chris
Chris hodus and da pennebaker who are
incredible filmakers wonderful
filmmakers um and we're such mentors to
me and they introduced me to this world
of documentary where you know we had
this wonderful dinner last night which
was so communal and wonderful and it
just um reminded me of everything that I
fell in love with entering this
community of people of crazy people that
do everything to get their film made and
spend years and years and um and I just
so I'm just so honored to be here with
all of you guys um so um well I made my
first film with them and then um I think
showing startup and seeing how people
reacted to character and how you know
people see a film and they want to know
about this character and they feel like
they're friends with them by the end of
the film and they want to know more
about them made me want to go um do that
more and also go back home where I felt
like people didn't know and weren't
friends with you know people from Egypt
or from you know from from from where I
come from and so I then made control
room at a time when the Iraq War was
happening because I desperately wanted
to humanize that struggle and what was
happening on the other side of the world
and um and then this film and I think
also there's also an incredible thing to
ver film making where um when we were
making startup.com we would be editing
and we were making this film about these
two guys who were in the middle of
the.com bubble and I would Escape down
to Penny Baker and Chris's library of
films and they made all these films in
the 60s and you know would put one in
and you'd be in the back of no narration
you'd be in the back of the car with Bob
Dylan and Joan bayz and it felt like the
closest thing you could get to time
travel you felt like you were in that
car with them um and I think I wanted to
do be able to do the same thing you know
in Egypt um and this story started for
me obviously I grew up in Cairo grew up
about 10 minutes away from the square um
and Mubarak came into power when I was 6
years old so um he's been with us quite
a while um and uh I made a film actually
in 2007 I followed the protest movement
for a very long time um I made a film
2005 and six that came out in 2007 um
called Egypt we're watching you which
was named after a group of three women
who were protesting um at a time when
protests would be maybe 20 people in the
street surrounded by hundreds of police
and all of our you know cameras would be
smashed and everybody would be in jail
um and then everybody would go home and
nobody would come back um and um so when
January was coming um of 2011 we were in
a time when Tunisia had just exploded um
and in the summertime there had been
this brutal um torture and killing of a
young man in the prisons named khid s
and a Facebook page had been created in
his name called we are all khed s and it
you know things were really rumbling in
Egypt but I grew up in an Egypt where
you couldn't have a conversation with a
taxi driver or somebody on the street
about how somebody you didn't know about
how you really felt about the political
situation people wouldn't say how they
really felt for fear of of repercussion
so to
see the masses coming down and then get
attacked and then not go home the next
day and stay and be joined by others was
the most beautiful thing and this is why
I make films is because I see something
beautiful and magical and I immediately
want to share it with the rest of the
world and I find characters that I fall
madly in love with and I want to share
them with the world and so there was so
going down there it was just this
absolutely beautiful moment and people
were saying um K describes this
conversation one of our characters of
the film describes this conversation he
was having at the time with a taxi
driver and this Taxi Driver told him
look it's either you take me or you take
me and my grandkids and my grandkids
grandkids so it's better you just take
me because I don't want to live in a
country full of corruption where we we
don't want to have kids in this country
anymore and that's I think how we all
felt and why we all wanted to be there
um and so that's really how the film
started but you know then the climax
happened really you know Mubarak stepped
down in 18 days it was this fairy tale
and how do you start a film with a
climax where do you go from there and
and then but then we sort of thought you
know this is actually where the real
struggle is beginning and the moment I
think we really felt this is where
things are just you know the story is
really started is when Romy the musician
that you see in the film um you know
weeks earlier had been heralded as a
hero of the Revolution and was on every
television station and Mubarak steps
down all the international cameras leave
the
square and there's a few people in the
Square still saying you know the secret
police is still in place the rest of OB
barak's government is still in place and
we have to we have to stay here and we
have to keep working for deep change and
the square is cleared and uh Ramy is
arrested and taken to the Egyptian
Museum and brutally tortured and not no
coverage of it anywhere and I had
pictures of him filmed by Ida another
woman in the film and I posted them on
my Facebook and friends of mine educated
friends of mine said there's no way that
the Army could possibly do this and I
was like okay there's a whole story that
is happening here that has to be covered
and we have to stay here and keep
covering it and and that's how it that's
how it started um I met uh everybody who
was on our team in the Square um I think
sometimes the way that you make art sort
of mirrors the art that you're making
and um it was sort of we kind of were
like um you know this has to be sort of
a leaderless film then nobody can be
blamed for making it right it's the same
what reason why the leaderless
revolution worked because nobody could
be targeted so we all came together in
this Square you mean when they ask who's
in charge nobody's in charge nobody's in
charge we're all in charge right we're
on everybody and nobody and you know it
will keep going no matter what um so um
well that that's also because of the
support of of a lot of people and and I
think that one thing I want to I just
want to thank everyone here and and the
audience and and and the stage for being
here because what's happened to us you
know we come from a country where the
symbol of power for 5,000 years has been
the pyramid and today the symbol of
power is the square and it's a sea of
people who are claiming their rights and
claiming the right to have to be authors
of their future and their story will be
told and will be heard around the world
because of all of you so I just want to
thank everyone here for
that and I initially thought Kareem
should be a character in the film so and
you'll see why when he to talks more but
he was what I went to the when I went to
the square there was the Brotherhood
setting up a stage in the Square there
was the um sort of very Lefty stage and
Kareem with with other few other people
was setting up a stage because we've
been living in a political vacuum and
nobody you know he said there's got to
be a place for people who don't know who
who they're affiliated with to be able
to go up and read a poem or whatever so
I started following him with a camera
and I followed him for about two weeks
and then he said you know I don't think
I want to be a character in this film um
but you definitely need a producer and
so he came on as the producer and so he
became a big character in your
life to get this together and and I
think in in in in what you know all
everyone's been so many this baton that
we're passing is is so incredible to
hear all the different stories and and
and the way that different
collaborations and have been made and I
think you know it to me it's really
what's so powerful about documentary
film and what so many people in this
room are are doing is it's the ability
to hold a mirror to society and and and
and and and and and celebrating
documentary is really celebrating the
those who stand with that mirror who are
willing to hold the mirror to societies
as changes happen to show the Beauty and
the ugliness as well and I think that
unless we do so as societies we're not
able to to to learn and move forward and
we allowing an environment where history
will continue to repeat itself you know
so so many of these films do that in so
many different ways uh whether it's in
the short form or the long form doesn't
matter and I think that we need to
continue to cherish that because we live
in a world today where the
interconnected power of humanity can be
the authors of the future in a way like
we've never had before and there's
something absolutely beautiful about
that you know when we see today the
image that fundamentally shifted Egypt
forever which is the Sea of people
crowded in a square Millions saying we
will write our future we will no longer
live in a a world where this our stories
already been written for us we will be
the authors of our future and we will
Triumph no matter how long it gets there
and to see that that that story can
inspire people around the world to stand
with them and and and that and that
audiences Like You Can level the playing
field because when the story started in
Egypt it was a lonely fight between the
the Egyptian protester versus the
Egyptian dictator but when the world
tuned in and the media reported and
people like Jeremy were covering and
everyone was covering what's happening
it beca it leveled the playing field
because it became a global fight and
when that happened the dictator fell and
that's the way that we can continue to
fight back and today when we see Square
after Square after Square
whether it's in KV or kakas or all
starting to to look very similar we know
that something fundamental is happening
that people power is rising and saying
we the people have the ability to write
a better story and the success of that
story is dependent on all of us
contributing so that's you know
something that I think we really need to
continue to to to help Channel those who
are holding these mirrors in different
parts of the world and trying to to
allow for these stories to be told uh
you know in our country in Egypt uh the
fight is very much still alive today at
a time when the Army is trying to
whitewash history uh and trying to reset
the buttons and say that we're just
going to pretend like none of this has
happened and go
back the the film being nominated for an
Academy Award has completely changed the
it's it's changed the entire
conversation because this is the first
Academy Award in Egyptian history and
and we're a country that loves Cinema
yeah the wonderful and and and our story
will be heard and we've already won
because of of of the the way that this
film is getting out there now the way
that it's sparking conversations in
Egypt and around the world we just had a
screening uh in Kiev actually two weeks
ago uh it was unbelievable in the Square
the film was translated by the
protesters into Ukrainian uh and then
they called us back and said well
actually it's minus 30 here and it's
kind of cold to read the subtitles I
mean I know some people in the audience
couldn't read it even here uh and so
they they they dubbed it into Ukrainian
uh and we released it there and over
300,000 people have downloaded it in
Ukraine uh and then they came back a
week later and said well actually we
want it now in Russian because you know
if we don't get it to Putin then you
know it it it's not just about the
Ukraine so we've released a Russian
version of the film uh and they've shown
it now uh in a square in Russia
uh and what's unbel able about releasing
stories like these online is that people
can join in the conversation immediately
so audiences can go from being audience
audiences to participants and connecting
with our characters online Skyping Ahmed
our main character who just met for a
few moments and I encourage you to meet
further uh and and and having him speak
to those squares they just had him speak
two days ago to the square in karakas so
I think that something fundamentally
incredible is happening and we're just
at the beginning of understanding not
only how it's going to impact our story
St and how we can participate in that
story but how we can continue to hold
power accountable so thank you for
having right and it's and it's also too
like the piss [__]
riots which you know were in Russia and
they just got beaten and also Skyping
with them everywhere and hearing their
story that we're not isolated anymore
that we can really get our stories out
and we can really get there and we can
really have some sense of solid ity and
action a call to action if you may the
successes and failures of these squares
is interdependent and that's what we're
starting to see today you know and so
it's especially because what's what what
the squares are breaking is is is how we
also viewed how change happens right so
when you start to see these alarm bells
that are happening all over the world
you start to realize that it's not just
a local fight it's a global fight right
and when you start to see that then you
start to realize like well we have to
start looking at the global causes of
these fights and start to to propose
solutions for them and I think that one
of the things that that we witness
happening is that unfortunately the
media doesn't like the story of change
because real stories of change take a
lot of time they don't fit in a column
and they can barely fit in a film be and
and I think we have to free ourselves
from this idea in this world of change's
greatest hits where we see you know we
see Martin Luther King say I have a
dream we see Gandhi liberating India we
see Mandela ending aarthi but we're not
willing to spend 20 years in jail with
Mandela because that's boring it doesn't
fit into our attention span and so I
think that is you know we that's how
what where we have to shift and we need
to you know celebrate documentaries as a
way to continue these
conversations
great okay 20 Feet from
Stardom hi I'm I'm Morgan Neville I'm
the director of 20t from Stardom and I'm
KRON Rogers I'm the producer of 20t from
Stardom
let me just say first off there should
be another seat here for us we have
another producer on our film Gil Fen and
uh this was his baby it was his initial
idea and he loved this film and he
worked with us right up until a few
weeks before we premiered it when he
passed away so um you know this whole
experience of the film and how it's been
received has been so bittersweet because
Gil's not here to to enjoy it because he
would have loved every minute of it
believe
me gil was a great guy who used to run
A&M records and he was um he was retired
and he when I met him this is how the
thing started he just said I think
there's something interesting about
backup
singers and it was only kind of half of
an idea and I thought well that's
interesting because I've made a lot of
films about music over the years and I
know a lot about music but I didn't know
anything about backup singers I had no
idea and he said well let's let's see if
if this hunch is correct and you know I
went home
um I went to the internet I tried to
look up backup singers I couldn't find
anything and there were no books
documentaries articles websites and it
kind of stunned me that there there was
this thing that we all kind of know
about and we've heard them but it was
just this invisible topic and that
excited me because it was something that
um that was Unwritten and the only thing
we could do to figure out what this film
would be before we even decided to make
the film was just to meet backup singers
and we spent several months right then
Kate and Kate came on board and we spent
three months I think um initially doing
50 oral histories with backup singers
ultimately I think we did about 80
and just
initially you know within days you know
I knew that there was this incredible
story and what I felt like we had
stumbled upon was a family and it was
this incredibly tight-knit family where
everybody knew each other and looked out
for each other and it was I had so many
misconceptions that were completely
blown away by the reality of these
people when I met them I was so happy to
be wrong you know I thought that maybe
they weren't as talented as lead singers
or maybe um they didn't have enough
character to their to their voice
um
I I expected them to be more kind of
competitive and bitter and all the
things that come along with the music
industry and there was none of that you
know they were just incredibly loving
supporting supportive people who were
the best music and they just oozed music
and they were the best artists that
nobody had ever heard of I mean it was
just like I can't believe you're this
this good and um I realized when I first
did this whole batch of interviews and I
said well what is the story here and I
kind of picked a narrative um which was
to me the kind of the real revolution in
this world which was the migration of
these voices largely African-American
female voices from the churches in into
the studios and on divinyl and then the
various iterations of that over
different
generations and um it was just a
story that
um you know initially I thought um okay
we're making a film about
African-American women and initially I
thought it might be a really depressing
film because
um because it's seems tragic that the
these people are not better known they
didn't have more success you feel bad
for them and I felt bad for them and
what I realized early on and was one of
the the big breakthroughs for me on
making the film was that they didn't
want me to feel bad for them and that
they are not bitter because
they've all made their own peace with
the lives they live rather than the life
they dreamt of having or rather than the
life that the music industry or Society
tells them they should be living and
realized that for many of them backup
singing is the best thing they could
have ever done you know it's the serer
decision it's the happier decision
and what I realized kind of halfway
through the film was that in a way this
was like the most personal film I'd ever
made because I found myself identifying
so deeply with these people you know
because I've been making documentaries
for 20 years and just their kind of
their humility their ethos their idea
that the work as its own reward you know
that um their pride in the craft I mean
all these things I just I was right
there with them I just I loved them and
I loved I love what they were talking
about
um and their voices and their voices you
know I I every time I was with I was
constantly trying to come up with
excuses to get them to sing anything say
how does that go or what's the harmony
just because to be in the presence of
talent like that is is amazing um and
the other thing they do every time still
to this day when I'm with them we'll be
in an elevator and a song will come on
and they'll say oh that's me singing you
know and it's like someday we'll be
together by The Supremes and I said but
that's the Supremes he said no it's me
you know it's like okay that's right and
there's also some wonderful antidotes
that many of them told you too uh Phil
Spectre story uh Bruce being a backup
singer Bruce Springstein sure I mean on
um kind of a music level um it's kind of
like a secret history of pop music you
know you get you get that out of it and
what it's all about is kind of a
paradigm shift that goes on in your mind
it's something I did early on and Kate
and everybody working on the film where
you suddenly take the things in the
background and try and consciously force
them to the foreground so I had the
radio on I was going through my record
collections I just everywhere I was
discovering backing vocals in songs I'd
heard a thousand times and never
realized they were there and never
realized the whole song was based on the
backup singing and once you kind of make
that cognitive leap then suddenly it
just it's everywhere and it was not only
in the in the music but then when we
were doing all of our research on the
film uh we call up every archive and
said send us everything you have on
backup singers and every single archive
said we have nothing and it's not that
they didn't have shots of singers it's
just that they're by their very nature
invisible
and you know suddenly once you focus
your eye on it they're they're
completely visible and I think you know
what one thing that's interesting to me
is that you know it's a story of um
these people who are their women they're
black and they're backup singers I mean
they're disenfranchised on so many
different levels yet like I said they
weren't um defeated by that and that
really inspired me maybe you could talk
a little bit about the Mary Clayton
story and and MC Jacker that's well the
Give Me Shelter story yeah I mean that's
one of those gim Me Shelter is a song
that's probably we've all heard it many
times it's one of the most legendary
backup singing performances of all time
but um you don't really I mean it's one
of these instances where you suddenly
hear it a new so Mary Clayton I'd found
the isolated vocal track on the internet
actually somewhere and she came for an
interview and I played it for her and
she had never heard it and you know it
just it well first of all she explained
to me what all the lyrics were which I
never knew rape murder it's just a shot
away I don't think most people right
knew exactly what it was she was singing
and then the story behind it about her
going to the studio getting a call in
the middle of the night and going to the
studio in a robe with curlers in her
hair doing the song three times so she
could get back to her warm bed as
quickly as possible and then when I was
able to interview Mick Jagger he told me
the same story I mean it fit perfectly
and I said okay this this wasn't BS this
was actually how this how this went down
and now you know when I hear that song
it it's completely different to me you
know which I love and I love taking
something familiar like that and making
you hear it a new making it you
completely um you know transform it in
your mind right and I think Mick said
you know if we didn't have her it would
just be me and me and me and maybe Keith
a little bit of Keith yeah yeah a little
bit of Keith and that Mary and her head
said I am just gonna sing something that
is going to blow them out of the water
exactly and she did and she did I that
was the first scene in the film that we
cut that was and we never Chang touch it
again yeah I mean there's one thing I
mean we talking about are we reflecting
uh as documentary filmmakers are we
reflecting people's stories are we are
we th
um I felt like a caretaker very much on
this film um I felt like these people
were interesting their stories to me
many of them were hesitant about it um
in part because the music industry and
by some extension being part of
entertainment because I had a camera you
know just feeling like I don't want to
be exploited and then I think many of
them had kind of made their bargain with
themselves about their relationship ship
to start them and the idea of even
talking about these things were is
drudging up these things they long since
buried and you know it took that you
know massive amounts of time and Trust
to get people to open up and and I
really did feel then like I had this
great responsibility and um you know we
had to we had to tell their stories the
best we possibly
could and do you feel that um you have
have been encouraged by what you heard
and we'll never look at backup singers
in the same way also the the political
and the racial divide that you may have
found I mean we these are amazingly
inspiring women and it was really kind
of an honor to be able to work with them
um and it wasn't always easy they are
sometimes
difficult I was sort of can say it I
became the diva Wrangler I think
which we all understand that um but they
taught me a lot and I you know I think
from the very beginning I realized that
there was so much to learn from these
amazing women and what did you learn
being a diva Wrangler we need your
help where to get calamari at midnight
in in Utah Utah
yeah you should uh I think
mainly that you have to have really
thick
skin and uh that you you know don't take
anything just put your foot down stand
up for
yourself Mary Clayton always told me I
always had to have my nails done and my
hair
done
which um and you know just stand up for
yourself and speak up for yourself and
you
know
go for it right and not be afraid of
them but I mean they're um I mean even
over you know they have the that kind of
exterior um but like I said it's once
you get past that which you get past
very quickly um they are so loving so
supportive um and i' I've told this
before that I mean they would call me
many of them would call because many of
them are they almost all came out of the
church and I think the church was
actually perfect training for them not
just for Harmony singing but for the
kind of psychological makeup you need
the idea of serving something greater
than yourself and I feel like they
learned understood that by coming out of
a church setting um and many of them
were they call themselves PKS preachers
kids um but they would call and say
we're praying for you Morgan we're
praying for the film we're praying
you're going to tell our story the best
way I mean I this went on for years I
was they would tell me this all the time
and I'm pretty sure it's the most prayed
over documentary in history at this
point
so I've got to give credit to them for
that you
know I just have uh one last question
for you which was what about the um
archival rights and the music Rights was
that difficult for you I mean it was
um yes it was difficult that's quick
answer uh from a rights pect perspective
it's about as difficult as a project
gets um we had a few things working for
us one was that Gil had been in the
industry for so long and knew so many
people and I'd done so much in the music
world that I knew a lot of people and we
realized very early on that we had one
great tool one and only great tool
working for us which was guilt you know
which we used mercilessly on everybody
um and Gil would always take people to
lunch cuz he said they couldn't say no
to them at lunch and he would hit them
up and say okay we need you to do this
for us we need this song we need this
footage we need this interview and you
know once we got a beach head with
enough people saying yes then we could
really use the guilt on everybody else
to hit them over the head and uh had
like 30 tracks from a million different
Publishers yeah it was it was
tough uh are there any last words by
anyone before before we end this
brilliant night I just wanted I think
everyone here probably has so many
people part of our teams that are in the
audience so I think anyone who's been a
part of these five films please stand up
now because y
yeah Remy
Remy
yeah these films take Villages or
squares to make and um sorry but they do
they take teams of people and you know
we're honored to be Representatives but
there's so many people back home in
Cairo and I know this whole group has
teams that we're so thankful
for and I just want to say to all of you
that your films have moved me and
influenced me
and I for one will do anything to talk
about them to get them out there and I
wish you all great luck on Sunday thank
you